[MUSIC PLAYING]
YURI GRINSHTEYN: If
you use Prometheus
to monitor your services
and infrastructure,
you probably have a
set of configurations
you've developed over months
or years that serve you really
well.
But managing and maintaining
them can be a challenge.
Today, I'm going to show you
how to migrate your existing
Prometheus setup, including
your application monitoring
configurations, to
Managed Collection,
and remove the need to
manage any part of Prometheus
at scale.
My name is Yuri, and I'm
an SRE at Google Cloud.
Welcome back to Engineering
for Reliability.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Prometheus Operator
is a common way
to manage Prometheus
deployments in production.
The Operator uses
custom resources
to manage the Prometheus
server itself.
You then define service
monitor resources
to configure how specific
services are monitored.
You can certainly use Prometheus
Operator with Google Cloud's
Managed Service for Prometheus.
But migrating to
Managed Collection
means you won't have to
manage any Prometheus
infrastructure at all.
Let's have a look at how to
migrate an existing Prometheus
configuration, managed
by the operator,
to Managed Collection.
Let's start by reviewing
our existing configuration.
We have a Prometheus operator
and the Prometheus server
running in the
monitoring namespace.
Our app is running in
the default namespace.
We can confirm
that it's exposing
Prometheus metrics on
the slash matrix endpoint
by using port-forward.
And there we are.
We instructed
Prometheus operator
to monitor our app by using
a service monitor resource.
Here's our configuration.
And here it is
deployed on the server.
We can use port
forwarding to confirm
that Prometheus has
our app as a target
and that it is ingesting
our app's metrics.
At this point, we're ready to
migrate to Managed Collection.
We're going to enable Managed
Collection in the Cloud console
here.
You can also do this
with a gcloud command.
If you're now running a GKE,
you can also use kubectl.
Once that's done,
we need to instruct
Prometheus to monitor our app.
To do this, we'll use a pod
monitoring configuration.
Managed collection uses pod
monitoring and resources
instead of service
monitors to guarantee
that each collector
only scrapes targets
on the nodes running now.
This guarantees
scalability by minimizing
intracluster traffic.
The configuration itself is
similar to the service monitor
resource, but you may need
to change some fields.
We'll link to the documentation
in the episode notes
so you can be sure
to get this right.
Let's apply this configuration.
At this point, we can confirm
that our application metrics
are being ingested by
querying them using PromQL
and in Metrics Explorer.
And that's how you can
migrate an existing Prometheus
configuration to Google's
Managed Prometheus collection.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
We learned how to migrate an
existing Prometheus operator
deployment to Google's
managed Prometheus collection
and how to use a pod
monitoring resource to ensure
that your service is monitored.
I hope this helps you keep your
services reliable and users
happy.
If you have any other
reliability or observability
topic you'd like me to
cover, please comment below.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.